today on the anime zone or a view of
High School of the Dead an anime about
zombies as Japan's first taken a zombie
apocalypse genre following a group of
survivors battling the vast army of the
undead with a cast of highly-trained
supermodels complete was over-the-top
balls to the walls physics breaking
action as if the whole thing was
programmed in the [__] matrix
speaking of the matrix are you trying to
tell me bullets
[Music]
at this point in time the zombie John
has a concept that has blunted death in
the Western media invading movies comic
books of video games and even novels
where it's got to the point that all you
need to do to advertise something is
slapping zombies in it and the thing
will sell out as if it came with
complimentary biscuits and [__]
surprisingly enough there hasn't really
been any anime centered around a zombie
apocalypse even when the medium of anime
gives the Japanese the chars play with
new and original takes of existing
genres all exploring Majan ative
settings that couldn't have been
presented in any other medium which
would have been perfect for a
reimagining of the zombie genre then
along comes High School of the Dead a
zombie apocalypse set in [__] high
school shine on Japan shined the [__] on
High School of the Dead is a 2010 anime
done by studio madhouse and follows the
progression of a zombie apocalypse seen
through the eyes of takashi kimura who's
basically a clone of Kazuki from Brisa
ranking but then again I'm pretty sure
super serious spiky head high school boy
takes up around 90% of all and rate
protagonists anyway one day what Akashi
is busy pondering while pinky promises
made in elementary school with an equal
guaranteed sex and casually pretending
to converse with the gir despite the
fact that her face is up here and not
down there he bears witness to a zombie
attack by what seems to be a zombie
version of bill from accounting from
their own panic ensues as cool as
everyone gets involved in the massive
biting frenzy and before you know it the
whole school has become an infected pit
of dead flesh before you can say you've
got red on you from here Takashi must
rise to the challenge as he forms a
ragtag team of survivors and faces the
biggest challenge of his life trying to
keep his [__] dick in his pants with
a bloody sex prayed constantly waving in
his face 24/7 and maybe surviving the
oncoming apocalypse in the process the
show plays out like your typical zombie
survival story with a group of unlikely
heroes teaming up to battle hordes of
the undead
wearing short skirts they cover about a
millimeter of skin but along the way
hinting at the fact that the real
monster in all this is instead mankind
itself and in the end the cause is what
you get if he crossed a zombie
apocalypse with your typical harem edgy
anime you have Takeshi who starts off as
the unwilling spiky haired hero who's
thrown into a situation where he is
forced to fight for survival and
transforms into the confident badass
leader who's not afraid to kick ass and
take names whoa occasionally asserting
his authority by bitch-slapping the odd
girl Rey the annoying [__] tease of a
heroine who flips between [__]
stuck-up girl who just lost her
boyfriend to helplessly the damsel in
distress so suffice to say she needs the
occasional bitch-slap to keep her in
line and again and again and now just
because I can
[Music]
takagi the brains of the group he was
the type of girl that our fuss over her
make up and tried to look pretty and put
on a strong fake aide in front of the
guy she likes but she forgets that in
real beauty it's the inside that really
counts her dreadful personality Kota
the chubby nut who's secretly a badass
with guns given the viewers some hope
that all that time [__] around a Call
of Duty may actually come in useful one
day psycho the badass swordswoman who
happens to think that dressing like a
porn star is the most practical battle
attire a lolicon because there wasn't
enough pandering in the show had finally
now if you've heard anything about this
show always infamous reputation you may
be expecting me to rip it to new
bollocks
so allow me to surprise some of you by
saying in some ways I actually enjoyed
this anime in the sense that it was just
pure mindless fun
yes cow - a typical story predictor went
completely shallow but it never tries to
hide what it's trying to be and does
exactly what it says in a tin with the
tin saying hot high school girls
fighting hordes of zombies with plenty
of blood wearing skimpy school uniforms
PS this is a popcorn flick through and
through it makes no attempt to disguise
it
the plot is nothing we haven't seen
before in previous zombie flicks but it
does well to portray the panic and rise
of the zombie infestation and post
apocalypse this keeps us interesting in
what happens in how society breaks down
in a dying world characters are pretty
much one-dimensional and not only really
that's fill-in their stereotypical roles
of kicking ass flashing skin or being
[__] useless but honestly you don't
go into a summer blockbuster expecting
Oscar material and and its best points
it's a fun and entertaining show to
watch animation is also top notch which
is especially evident during the very
well-executed action scenes in which all
of the high school kids apparently tap
into that in a b-movie action hero and
spontaneously transforming to the cause
of the Expendables with tits this
resulted in some heart-pounding
over-the-top bolstered of always action
reminiscent of my experience at Black
Lagoon another series done by madhouse
where the action scenes were stupid
defied the laws of physics and will
ridiculous to look at yet were bloody
awesome hold on a second
over-the-top action a class of stupidly
attractive female characters explosions
a scene with the presidents this is a
Michael Bay movie
I stayed up late on the night before the
no wait it needs some Linkin Park mr.
president
now of course there's no way to go
through this review without talking
about the fanservice so as for that I
thought I said all I needed to about
edgy shows my equitation review but with
highschool of the dead it's a slightly
different cases if it went without the
borderline pornography it wouldn't
totally suck no pun intended
see the show self was actually quite
well done and without the fanservice it
would have been a respectably
entertaining series but any chance of it
getting taken seriously he's thrown out
the window when the crater's thought to
themselves you know what we could create
a fun yet respectable anime that takes a
serious look at a post-apocalyptic
zombie-infested world but [__] that this
is gonna be watched by guys guys have
dicks dicks like these so let's throw
them a bunch of tits and wait for our
big pile of money
this results in some of the most
distracting and downright annoying
ounces of fanservice that breaks any
kind of immersion you may have had in
any serious scene see as much as I like
to rant about fanservice I'm all for it
as long as it doesn't get in the way of
the actual good stuff and in highschool
of the dead they wave it in your face
whatever the setting context or tone a
scene maybe in creating one pretty sure
what is a new concept in modern
cinematography of the classic breast
dive you shot no mana Wasco gone the
camera angle is always situated at the
most revealing position possible and on
a side note my belts are longer than
these [__] shorts where was I again
oh yeah breasts every breast in the show
seems to have their own physics engine
by that the anime completely ignores an
old invention called the bra boobs
almost large enough to collapse in on
themselves to create a singularity and
each individual boob has a mind of its
own with the slightest nudge apparently
signaling the start of a breast rave
party
[Music]
and also tits cannot do this I think and
this is a real shame because there is a
lot of good in the show which is easily
overshadowed by the [__] tits waving
in your face for the subject of dubs all
subs this is a tricky one actually on
one side the sub is better acted but on
the other hand the dub is just a lot
more fun you could tell the translators
were having fun since the script is
heavily rewritten adding a variety of
pop-culture references from Romero films
to Sarah Palin jokes I'm not even joking
and also adding the word [__] every
few sentences so take your pick would
you rather have a more refined better
acted version or one that doesn't take
yourself too seriously and it's just
having fun because as we know adding the
word [__] makes everything cooler and
funnier it's [__] Sunday and I've
gotta go to [__] work in four [__]
hours because every other [__] in my
[__] department is [__] ill that
can you see why I'm so [__] angry
[__] yeah overall high school of the
dead it was a mixed bag of fun it really
is nothing but - entertainment but it
knows what it is it never tries to be
anything more than that so if you've got
some time to waste someone or sure
zombies getting splattered to some well
animated and choreographed action scenes
then go right ahead just make sure you
have your fanservice filters on because
you will get exposed to so much of this
[__] your body is sure to start an
immunity against it currently high
school the vet is licensed by Sentai
Filmworks and is available through legal
streams that Netflix Hulu or the Anime
Network and just in case one of those
[__] who skip right to the end of the
review to see the score without actually
watching it's what here's my review in a
nutshell